ouais on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
j'ai regardé votre caméra c'est le cas
le rouge et vous il ya elle vous
regardez celle qu'elle a donc on va le
faire pour la première fois un lancement
croisés si la voile afin qu'on fait ça
c'est la france travaille avec et des
magnétos l'autre qui dit serge voilà
vous dites magnéto et vous vous dites ch
attendu inverse
non non vous changez de cette émission
cette édition est déjà assez compliqué
comme ça à faire laurent magnéto vous et
vous vous dites c'est attention on va
s'arrêter juste quand les gens
commencent à maron l'émission à 2,3 à
temps que vous le faites si vous êtes
très bien sûr on est d'accord là dessus
faut que tu sois prêt attention vous
êtes prêts attention il étudie faire
attention
1 2 3